[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم في حلقه جديده وصالون جديد
من برنامجكم الندوه حديثنا اليوم سيكون
ممتزا
باشوات السياسه ورائحه النفط العلاقه بين
هذين العنصرين لا يمكن ان يفك عن بعضهما
ونشاهد ونراقب كل يوم الجدل في وسائل
الاعلام وفي عناوين الاخبار الرئيسيه لا
تنفق رائحه النفط تتسلل الى عناوين
الاخبار وبالذات حول منظمه اوبك بلس
وبالذات اكثر حول حجر الزاويه في هذه
المنظمه المملكه العربيه السعوديه ما هي
قصه العلاقه بين النقط والسياسه كيف نفهم
اليات محركات هذا الصناعه الكبرى التي
يعتمد عليها اقتصاد العالم لا بل هي شريان
الاقتصاد العالمي ولا اجده بصراحه افضل
للحديث حول هذا الموضوع من رجل هو كما
تقول العرب قديما ابن مجدتها في هذا
مجال الدكتور ابراهيم بن عبد العزيز
المهنا نائب رئيس مجلس اداره الجمعيه
السعوديه الاقتصاديات الطاقه وهو الى ذلك
من اهم خبراء او مستشاري الطاقه الاسعاء
المستوى السعودي فقط بل على المستوى
العالمي وهو الى ذلك وهو سبب استضافتنا او
تشرفنا باستضافه اليوم مؤلف كتاب حظي
بمراجعات كبيره جدا صدر له باللغه
الانجليزيه بعنوان قاده النفط او اويل
ليدرس حياك الله دكتور ابراهيم في هذه
الحلقه
وكتابنا معك الذي حظي بمراجعات كثيره جدا
همم على امل ان شاء الله ان تصدر منه
النسخه العربيه القديمه سادخل في الموضوع
مباشره لانه لا وقت همم
نضيعه في المقدمات والتفاصيل خاصه مع رجل
صاحب الخبره النفط سلعه سياسيه او سلعه
اقتصاديه بحته
اول شي اشكرك على هذه الاستضافه وهذا
المقدمه الرائعه ثانيا جميع السلع يمتاز
يمتزج احيانا فيها النفط او في السياسه مع
السلعه نفسها جميع السلع بدون استثناء
امين بما في ذلك سلعه مثل الشاهي وكذا
الثوره الامريكيه لما قاموا ضد بريطانيا
كان يسمونها ثوره الشعب
ولكن احنا في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بشكل خاص وفي دول اوروبا بشكل عام لاننا
نعتمد واقتصادياتنا ودخلوا شعوبنا تعتمد
البترول نسعى
دي جميع الطرق ان نجنب
السياسه او نبعد السياسه عن البترول يعني
بمعنى اخر ان تكون السياسه البتروليه
مرتبطه فقط باوضاع السوق وبالذات من ناحيه
العرض والطلب حيث هدفا الرئيسي هو توازن
السوق واستقرارها على المدى القصير
والطويل ولذلك السياسه من جانبنا بعيده عن
البترول
ولكن بعض الدول لا شك انها تدخل السياسه
في البترول هل السعوديه تسعى لمصالحها
الذاتيه فقط البعض يتهممها بهذا العمر
بالذات في الصحافه الغربيه وبالذات في
الصحافه الامريكيه انها تسعى لمصالحها
مباشره او هي تسعى الى مصالح ال- ال-
المنظومه التي تنتمي اليها منظومه بلس او
الاقتصاد العالم كله هذه شبكات داخلها
شبكه داخله اللي هو مصلحه المملكه بس
بيتها اكبر دوله
مصدره للبترول وتمارس الاق سعودي على
البترول
واحتياطياتا هائله ستمتد باذن الله الى
ثمانين عاما او اكثر وفي نفس على الاقل
يعني حاسب الانتاج الحالي وفي نفس الوقت
لنا علاقه قويه مع دول منتجه اخرى بهدف
تنظيم السوق والعمل معا من اجل توازنها
قال لي هو الاوبك والاوبك بس
ثالثا الاقتصاد العالمي الاقتصاد العالمي
طبعا يهمنا نموه وقوته يجب ان ننسى
موضوع عن هام جدا ان الطلب على البترول
واستلامته يعتمد على وضع الاقتصاد العالمي
وصحه الاقتصاد العالمي ونمو الاقتصاد
العالمي في الدرجه الاولى ولذلك هذه
المنظومه الثلاثيه
تهمنا جميعا بدون بدون ان نفرق بين هذا
الارتباطهما مع بعض اذا السعي السعودي الى
استقرار هذه السوق ليس سعيا حديثا لا بل
ان ورد في مقدمه الكتابه التي كتبها باب
الله احد ايضا الخبراء في هذا المجال
الامريكان عباره لفتتني بصراحه نقلها عن
من وصفه بمؤرخ النفط السابق نورمان نورد
هاوسر وهي عباره لا كانه يتحدث عن عن ازمه
اليوم عن الاداره الامريكيه اداره يقول
هذا الخبير او المؤرخ نفطي الامريكي يمكن
النظر الى تاريخ النفط على ان هو بين
قوسين السعي وراء الاستقرار السعوديه لم
تخترع جديدا
هذا الامر هذا يعني الصناعه بدات في
امريكا اصلا يعني وهذا احد خبراءها يقول
هذا الكلام فما الظاهر على السعوديه حينما
تسعى الى الاستقرار ولماذا الهجوم اليوم
على السعوديه في الميديا الغربيه ما هو
تفسير الكلام والله الهجوم هي احيانا
مصالح سياسيه في الدراجه الاولى
ويعني وشعور
بان القرارات
هذه الدوله هذه سبب الرئيسي في الهجوم اما
ما مساله المصلحه العامه لا المملكه فهي
ثابته واستقرار البترول واحد من ضمنها
واستقرار البترول وهدف من الاستقرار
البترول موجود قبل الاوبك وقبل حتى
لما كانت تدير السوق نوعا ما يسمى
بالاخوات السبع كانت تسعى الى استقرار
السوق وتجتمع سنويا
شركات بتروليه في العالم اللي هي تضم
بترول اليوم بيغيروا اسمها وشال واكسبه
قبل الاخوات السابع كان يوجد ما يسمى
تكساس في الرود كوميشن اللي هي مصلحه
الطرق الحديديه في تكساس في ذلك الوقت
كانت امريكا هي البلد الرئيسيه في الانتاج
وشركات البترول الامريكيه هي الرئيسيه
وكان الانتاج ياتي من ولايه تكساس من قبل
عده
شركات ولا تريد تلك الشركات اغراق السوق
ولذلك تريد ان
توازن السوق وتحافظ على توازننا من خلال
تقرير كميات الانتاج
والسياب الانتاج لماذا ذلك الوقت كان
البترول ينقل عن طريق سكك الحديد
ولهذا السبب كان كان الاستقرار كان هدف
التكسي همم قبل ذلك جميع من بداوا في
الانتاج هدفهم الاستقرار لماذا تقول
الاستقرار لان ليس مصلحه ذاتيه ولكن
البترول
يحتاج الى استثمار بعيد المدى
واموال طائله
لا تستطيع ان تترك السوق بدون توازن والا
انهارت السوق توقفت الاستثمارات
حصل شحن
وارتفعت الاسعار بشكل نهائي
بدايه البترول كسلعه تجاريه وهامه
وبدات السيارات
وغيرها استقرار السوق استاذ ابراهيم على
ذكر امريكا والنفط الان هلا اضئت لنا يعني
انا انا يعني النقطه تهمني كثير علاقه
امريكا بالبتروليه بدات الصناعه هناك في
الاساس يعني امريكا كيف نصفها اليوم هل هي
منتجه او مصدره همم قصه منتجه مصدره او
مستهلكه وما هو الموقف من المخزون النفطي
لديه يعني ضع لنا امريكا في الشارع خاصه
انها هي دول اخرى ذكرتها روسيا كندا
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الامارات همم
العراق هي تح-
60 او 60% من الانتاج العالمي اذا هي دوله
من عمالقه النفط يعني ما هو موقفها
الطبيعي في هذا السوق في البدايه في القرن
بدايه القرن العشرين هيك كانت الدول
المسيطر هو الوحيده والوحيده على صناعه
البترول ليس داخل امريكا عالميه طبعا قبل
اكتشاف البترول في العراق
وقبل احتجاجه في ايران حتى بعد الاكتشافات
تلك امريكا هي الدوله الرئيسيه ترامب الان
لا زالت امريكا اكبر دوله مستهلكه في
العالم مستهلكه اكبر دوله
تصدر البترول
يعني دوله مهمه يضاف الى ذلك بان شركاتها
منتشره في جميع انحاء العالم ولا اقصد فقط
الشركات البترول لا شركات الخدمات
البتروليه كالحفر غيره وشركات الاستثمار
والبنوك جميعها تدخل في هذه المنظومه وهي
امريكيه والسوق السوق التي لا يتحدث عنها
كثيرا للناس اللي يسوق همم السوق
المستقبليه للبترول
تباع وتشترك في نيويورك لندن في الدرجه
الاولى وبدرجه الاقل
ولو هذه السوق مهمه جدا في تكوين الاسعار
اكثر من اي شيء اخر اذا هي فاعله في هذا
المجال انتاجا واستهلاكا وكانها تقدم
نفسها انها دوله تعتمد على الطاقه الخضراء
او الطاقه النظيفه كما يستر طاقه الرياح
والشمس بهذه المناسبه انا دفعت انتباهي
ايضا ذكرت انه حتى لنصل الى مستوى عملي في
الطاقه البديله لا من معوائد ماليه من دول
البترول حتى يتم الاستثمار في هذه الطاقه
ال- ال- البديله ولا لا يا دكتور والله
اشوف
ما يسمى بالطاقه الخضراء او او
همم المتجدده طاقه الرياح وال الشمس هذه
تبغى احتياج لا زالت في طور البدايه
وتكلفتها عاليه من ناحيه ومن ناحيه
الثانيه هو الاهم واللي مسوي مشكله الان
ان الجماعات الخضر جماعه الطاقه النظيفه
يكونون همم قوه ضغط كبيره قوه ضغط سياسيه
كبيره في امريكا مرتبطه بالحزب الديمقراطي
وتؤثرون بدون
بشكل كبير
على السياسه الامريكيه داخليا وخارجيا في
السماء
الحاليه بدا الغرب يعيد النظر لا يقبض
ولكن في نفس الوقت بدا يرجع للفحم يرجع
الطاقه
باعمال عنيفه يعني يرشون بويه يعني بس هذه
نرجع لها وهرجع كمان بعد الفاصل الاجانب
الذاتي من قصه ابراهيم المهنا مع ربكم مع
البترول فلا تذهب بعيدا ثم قصص مثيره بعد
الفاصل انتظرونا
اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد حديثنا عن النفط
والسياسه والطاقه البديله وحكايه البترول
والنقل السعوديه وضيفنا كان وما يزال
الدكتور ابراهيم بن عبد العزيز المهنا
نائب رئيس مجلس اداره جمعيه الاقتصاديين
السعوديه للطاقه اقتصاديات الطاقه وايضا
هو مستشار على مدى عقود في وزاره الطاقه
السعوديه ومستشار عالمي ايضا
وسبب المباشر لاستضافتنا له هو هذا الكتاب
الرائع والجميل الذي الفه الدكتور ابراهيم
المهنا وحظيا بصدا كبير حول بعنوان قاده
النفط السعوديه قصه اربع عقود حول تقلبات
السياسه بمراجعات كبيره هو طبعا الصدر عن
دار من اهم همم دور الراقيه في الغرب وهي
جامعه كولومبيا ذراع النشر لجامعه
كولومبيا كلهم بيعمل بريس وحظيا بمراجعات
كبيره جدا لانه فعلا هذا مش مجامله
لضيفنا العزيز او شريكنا العزيز الكتابات
السعوديه في هذا العطاء الاطار قليله جدا
للاسف يعني ثمه اشياء يعني نقول جزر لكن
ما يوجد فرديه متكامله ومن جيل الى جيل هو
الجميله انه بدا من عقد الثمانينات ااه
فما بعد والا في القصه اقدم من ذلك منذ ان
بدا تدفق النفط المملكه العربيه السعوديه
في منتصف الثلاثينات في عهد الملك عبد
العزيز اذا هي دعوه بصراحه مني انا لكل
مسؤول في السعوديه او في في العرب بس
بالذات في السعوديه والخليج ان يكتب
تجربته بهذه الشفافيه وبهذا التنوع بهذه
الحميميه التي كتب بها الدكتور ابراهيم
الاكثر في هذا حتى نشجع الناس على العوده
الى الموضوع كن قبل الفاصل تتحدث عن
انه جماعات الضغط الخضراء الطاقه البديله
تحولوا اليوم الى اداه ضغط سياسيه لا
تنطلق من معايير معقوله او عمليه في موضوع
الطاقه بقدر ما هي ايدلوجيا مناخيه
فكيف شايف ان هل تكتلات هذه المناخيه ممكن
تشكل ضغط على صناع القرار في الغربيه
جدا
ومؤثره على بعض الجهات كما ذكرت على الحزب
الديمقراطي في امريكا وعلى جهاد ثانيه في
اوروبا
وخارج اوروبا
وسوف تستمر ولكن المصالح
الاساسيه الوطنيه
مرحله اعاده التنقيب عن البترول بالذات
البترول الصخري في بريطانيا عندما اوقف
ذلك لفتره طويله وقفت مره اتحدث معهم
قلت لها يعني تكرهوا البترول قال نعم
سنقضي عليه قلت ملابس هذه من فين
سكت قلت الطاوله هذه اللي تعطن عليها
المنشوراتك وين كل هذه الاشياء البتروليه
يعني سكت ولم يستطيع الرجل
مهمه لانه في تصور نمط يعني البترول وكانه
هذا الوقود الاسود والبنزين او الديزل فقط
لكن هو صناعه معقده يعني همم اظن ان كان
قرات مره تدخل حتى في الاشياء الطبيه يعني
تدخل في الجميع في جميع الصناعات تقريبا
وميزاتها انها مارينا
انها رخيصه نوعا ما يسهل نقلها يعني فيها
ميزات كثيره استفاد العالم منها فيها
اشياء كثيره جدا تصور ان ليس لدينا صناعات
بترك كيميائيه الان في العالم والبترول
كام صناعات البركانيه مرتبطه بالبترول
والغاز الطبيعي تصور ليس لدينا الناس لن
يجدوا ما يكفيهم من الملابس من الاشياء
هذه الارض لن تستطيع انتاج كميات هائله من
القطن وغير ذلك
لصناعه البترول والغاز الطبيعي طيب على اي
اساس اذا ما دام قوام حياه البشر على هذه
الامور ما هو
المنطق هؤلاء ممكن هؤلاء نقول انه شطاء
متحمسين يعني يقول اللي يقول واحد برا
المسؤوليه يقول اللي يقول سنتكلم عن
السياسيين اللي يعرفون حقائق الامور
اتفضل حقائق والامور صحيح ولكن في ناحيتين
اللي ذكرت الماضي والثاني والثاني وهو بعد
مهم جدا ان ثاني اكسيد الكربون الذي يخرج
من البترول في السيارات والطائرات يؤثر
كما يقول يذكر العديد من العلماء على
التغير المناخ
الفارق وجهه نظرنا نحن في المملكه
يقول ان العالم كله في حاجه للجميع مصادر
الطاقه سواء همم البترول او الغاز او
الطاقه المتجدده الطاقه الشمسيه ولكن يجب
ان نحمل على جهتين توسع او ثلاثه همم
محاوره توسع في انتاج الطاقه الشمسيه
وطاقه الرياح كما نعمل لها الثاني محاربه
محاربه همم
تغير المناخي وثاني اكسيد الكربون عن طريق
عن طريق
تخفيف الكميات
الناتجه عن هذا مثلا سمى المملكه بدات فيه
بشكل كبير اللي هو حقا اعاده حقن ثاني
الكربون في الحقول بدل ما يطلع لل-
والثالث طبعا مبادره ولي العهد سمو الامير
محمد
المملكه الخضراء الشرق الاوسط المؤتمر شرم
يعني وهذه كل هذه الاشياء وهذه الطرق
وغيرها تساهم في تخفيض ال ال ال
الباحثات من ناحيه وفي صالح البيئه بدل ما
ان نحارب مصدر واحد لا يجب ان ننظر لها
بشكل اكبر من السعوديه وهي تبادر لموضوع
الطاقه المجتمع الاخضر
وحمايه البيئه تجاوزت حتى المعايير
العالميه يعني قرات مره انه المعايير
العالميه للمحميات الطبيعيه همم هي 17% من
مجمل مساحه البلاد السعوديه الان وصلت الى
20% يعني قصدي هذه هذه رغبه ذاتيه وليست
مجاوره او خضوع للاخرين لكن انا برجع شوي
الموضوع ذاتي اكثر من الموضوع همم الموضوع
يعني الموضوع البعيد عن الذات همم كيف ترى
نفسك بعد ان خرجت من قريه داخله في سدير
همم تسكن تلك البيوت الطينيه لم يتجاوزوا
100 فرد
ثم لم ترى الكهرباء في حياتك الا في عمر
الرابعه عشر تقريبا حينما زرت الرياض
وكان دخوله الكيروسون عليكم او الغاز في
القريه حدث ثوري يوازي نظريه كوبرنيكوس في
الفلكيه وبعدين صرت من النخبه العالميه في
هذا المجال كيف تصف هذه النقله وهل هي
ابراهيم المهنا يعكس تحول المجتمع كامل
يعني
تحول الي صار حصل لي ناس في جيلي جيلي اول
شيء الحكومه السعوديه يعني الملك عبد
العزيز واستمرت بعد ذلك الى فتح المدارس
فتح المدارس
كان مرحله مهمه جدا جدا بدات في الخمسينات
وانا صغير قبل فمه التوسع فيها ثانيا
الاعتمام الاهتمام بالصحه بالصحه العامه
زياره اطباء القرى الفقيره هذه
وبعدين تدرج الشيء بشكل
المعاهد المعلمين لتعطيهم رواتب مجزئه
وجيده ولكن نقله
ليه فيكم القران في نجد
ما عدا الرياض اللي كانوا يطور شكل كبير
كانت نقله كبيره يعني ثوره لما اقول
الكوريسين كمثال يعني انا اتذكر امي تطبخ
الله يرحمها تطبخ عن طريق ايش عن طريق
الحطب
وبقايا الجمال هذا
وتجميع الحطب وانواعه والدخان والمشاكل
الصحيه المرتبطه في العمليه ما هي بسيطه
لما اجي تكون خلاص
تنظر الى المنازل تشوف دخان من كل بيت
توقف هذا كله وتوقف الحطب وتوقف هذا ثوره
ثوره مين بسيطه ابدا
اعتمدت في كتابك على مقاربه الشخصيات انه
كيف انه صحيح هي صناعه لها اصوله
وقوانينها ومحركاتها لكن ايضا يلعب دور
الشخصيه تلعب هي اللي تسهر في النهايه كل
هذه الامور
وتضع القرار الاخير عاصرت مجموعه من وزراء
البترول والطاقه في البلد من احمد زكي
يماني مرورا به هشام ناظر وعلي النعيمي
وهمم والفالح وصولا الى صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان الوزير الحالي
الذي همم ايضا اصبح له هو كان وما زال لكن
اصبح لاعبا محوريه ايضا في في هذا المجال
باختصار كيف تصف تجربتك المديده مع هذه
الشخصيات القياديه هنتكلم عن المستوى
الوزاره
هذا لا يوجد في اي كتاب في العالم
الكتب التي تتحدث عن عن البترول
والطاقه دائما تركز على الجانب الاقتصادي
العرض والطالب وخلافه او الجانب السياسي
او تداخل ما بين السياسه والبترول مثلا لا
تجد احدا يتكلم بما فيه الكفايه ما فيه
التحليل الجيد عن دور الشخصيات الشخصيات
انا في وجهه نظري في هذا الكتاب انا لا
اعتقد ان دور الاقتصاد او السياسه وغيرها
لا مهمه ولكن الشخصيات لم تعطى همم دورها
الحقيقي واهميه التي تستحق ولذلك على ليس
الموضوع ولما تتكلم عن شخصيه القاده سواء
يماني ناظر على النعيم كما ذكرت او غيرهم
من رؤساء الدول
فهيق شخصيه
ما هي بسيطه ما هي بسيطه ابدا لماذا لانها
بسيطه الان يتعمل عوامل نفسيه
عوامل تاريخيه للشخص واهم من هذا كل
المعلومات التي يحصل عليها من الجوانب
المراكز الابحاث والدراسات حول قضيه ما
بتروليه وطريقه وطريقه وطريقه اييه تفسير
هذه المعلومه وتحليلها اضافه الى ذلك ان
الاعلام يلعب
فتره طويله في هذا الامر يعني كنت نقطه
التقاطع بين السياسه والاقتصاد والاعلام
وما ادراك ما الاعلام وعلى ذكر الاعلام ان
شاء الله ان شاء الله نتمنى ان تكون هذه
بدايه وليست نهايه وانتصر لنا ايضا تجاربك
اخرى همم وعلى امل ايضا ان يتشجع همم
صناع التنميه السعوديه في كل مجالاتها من
جيل حضرتك وربما اللي سبقوله اشراكنا نحن
ومن بعدنا في كيف صنعت المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وكيف صنعت سياساتها في خاتمه
المطاف انا اشكرك دكتور ابراهيم بن عبد
العزيز المهنا احد همم خبراء هذا المجال
والذين كان اغلب عملهم خلف الكواليس
واليوم على الطاوله اسال الله لك العمر
المديد ان شاء الله والانتاج الغزير
والاكثر كما اشكركم مشاهدين على كرامه
المتابعه والى لقاء قريب
[موسيقى]